[Music]
you are responsible for bringing back
the glamour of curls
oh well back
he started it what do you know started
it
that was Barbara Bush with her favorite
designer Arnold Scaasi in 1997 she loved
pearls and when she wore a triple strand
pearl necklace to her husband's
inauguration she sparked a national
trend there were other memorable moments
with et with Arnold Schwarzenegger at
the White House the annual Easter Egg
Roll Christmas in Washington and the
premiere of my stepmother is an alien
but when et spent time with mrs. Bush
through the years he usually wasn't
about Hollywood or fashion but her
literacy campaign you love don't you
mrs. food Beth very much
congratulations Miami Valley we were
behind the scenes with the first lady as
she taped promos for storytime with mrs.
Bush in 1991
remember kids who love to listen our
kids love to read and look her beloved
dog Millie a springer spaniel was right
at her side have you ever seen pictures
of the Rose Garden when the president
speaks the first lady told us why she
put reading in the spotlight children
who were read to do better in school
makes really for a better home life
there's just an awful lot of good things
that come from being read to when you're
young the former first lady had 14
grandchildren she was also the first
woman to be both a president's wife and
the mother of a president what do you
want the bush legacy to be the children
and the grandchildren they all do
something for others they do public
service they do something for others at
the end of your life you will never
regret not having past one more test
winning one more verdict or not closing
one more deal you will regret time not
spent with a husband a child a friend or
a parent